normally antalya sport would be much
busier at this time of year the
excursion boat skippers complained that
business is down by fifty to seventy
percent they charge about ten euros for
a two hour tour ghazal good who moved to
Turkey from Germany thinks the high
season could still be saved the tourist
seasons just now getting us started here
in Antalya and if the terrorism eases up
again if there aren't any more bomb
attacks we can still hope it will pick
up in June July August and September
those are the months when we make our
real money better late than never as we
say even so he's thinking about selling
one of his five boats and becoming a
fisherman getting out of the business is
not an option for Fatah to Mincy he's
just invested half a billion euros in
developing a luxury hotel and amusement
park with water coasters and other rides
in bellick near antalya he's counting on
recouping his investment within ten
years to Mincy built and owns the Rixos
hotel chain with 32 properties across
Europe and the Middle East more are
being planned
I continue to invest this is one of the
biggest investment for me and also for
tourism in Turkey we do something
similar in Istanbul also as a tourism
destination because I am creating
destinations not just a hotel the
amusement park called the land of
Legends will be opening in May the hotel
opened in February from 20 to 30
thousand visitors per day are expected
for the park twice as many as Disneyland
Paris receives but that's hardly
realistic as long as the beaches are
empty at the moment the hotels have
barely any guests at all the few who
come stay on the grounds but is it
actually dangerous in Antalya most of
the guests have already heard this
question from worried friends and
relatives the world is full of terror at
the moment so definitely people are
scared and that's probably why they they
reject you to go places like like Turkey
because it's close to Syria and how
comes that you don't have this opinion
well I mean it's a tourist place and
it's a bit offseason so if I was a
terrorist
I would not hit the place like this it's
not so much the danger as the fear
that's the problem the bookings for the
peak season have already dropped
radically at the same time the cost of
security is rising we have much more
people on security but there as we can
say our guests cannot see them they are
like invisible so that nobody is
uncomfortable over the past few decades
tourism in Antalya has grown by leaps
and bounds as one hotel after another
popped up some 12 million tourists come
annually one who's watched it all happen
is Hussein barriner he's been consulting
for German travel agencies for
nearly four decades in these 39 years
we've been through a lot of crises in
1993 we even had bombs going off in
Antalya three Germans died the next year
we had a record year from 1994 to 99 we
had some really major problems with
terrorism and 2000 was another record
here so we're not giving up millions of
Europeans and Germans know Turkey very
well and we've never said Turkey was
perfect Kenan does then the Army is
actualized perfect nobody can guarantee
that Turkey is absolutely safe but
that's no reason the coming year can't
set another record for tourism on the
Turkish Riviera